[Music]
tried to rent a place in the mission
so i opened up the page to the listing
and i'm just like damn
it's 17 grand
so i go to city hall ask a question
any chance that we can have new
construction and they're like no way
that's not okay
see we made the deduction that we need a
big reduction of any brand new
construction you kidding that really
suctions okay
[Music]
now let's open up for public debate what
[Music]
and they're just like oh
a community mart
not in my backyard i work in this town
you need to calm down
our community is great if you don't know
to change its character would be loco
our neighborhoods needs
that guy just crapped on the streets
homes of luxury are in outrage
low income housing's what we want made
with new construction killed
that kind of housing's being built
this region's added jobs by the gobs
that's led to mobs of folks driving here
in their sobs and they're pausing
because there's nowhere to go
gentrifiers
and sticks and stones never build new
homes so
[Music]
this isn't that hard
not in my backyard
and they're just like
you need to just stop
this is a crosswalk i work in this town
you need to calm down
[Music]